ouais mais laissez-moi juste donner un coup comme
ça maintenant ce que nous allons pomper votre
côté gauche Bennett venant mieux
il y a eu un très très bon David
42 000 nous pouvons éviter une nuit
Katherine a en fait eu une finale pour monter le
pont de verrazano
Je prends ceux qui me nourrissent passent ces
trois ici sous cette petite diapositive
sur le couvercle ouais c'est mieux ce que cela a
conduit ok voir si c'est pour plus pour le
droit l'armée le téléphone orange
conteneurs et trucs
voyage nous venons de faire un point  sortir un grand
cercle autour d'ici et ils veulent plus de
filles, ils donnent juste en quelque sorte aux ventes le
choix de ce que je vais être plus
au sud là-bas ouais que les
gens de la Garde côtière me détestent d'accord, ça fait des mangues
des vainqueurs de cicatrices qui se
battent tous contre ça  la chambre à coucher 500 ppm l'a
piraté l'un des gars vraiment fibreux
dans le gars de la République ou le marathon un homme riche de
900 pieds au nord
spécifiquement
dr.  entrer dans le bassin du bateau tourner
oui prostré vers signifiait que nous avons
une dispute directe à moins au cours de l'année
mais je suis au pouvoir à droite de la
crise j'ok donc beaucoup de Christ aux gouverneurs
sont sur les photos gouvernement ça va  obtenir
les grues aller autre feuille à court
terme ouais
tout sur l'
angle du sénat Delta Wendell Winston
Floria pépin le bloc maintenant pour en avoir un
planant au-dessus de
n'importe quel puits pourquoi ne volons-nous pas vers la
statue du côté ouest obtenir de la nourriture d'
accord je serai  dit qu'ils vont à une
heure garder les armes qui sont devant leur cœur
trop loin ouais quand quelque chose allait être
six heures ou trente sécurité d'accord hé
comme cette fois passera l'arrière de la
statue comment est-ce ouais je t'ai juste
donne-moi  c'est injuste amical merci Pete
builders club en plein air au gouverneur
sera autour de la batterie Thornton au
milieu de la rivière J'ai l'île de notre gouverneur
ou que new york fed 802 s'est avéré que cet
homme était la norme pour les plus grands
car cela rend toute loi encourager
un  une  méthode éprouvée gars narguilé sur un
cœur du gouverneur oh après droite, ils
nous ont jetés il y a 30 ans,
ils criaient sur le Selom pour un million de
combattants en leur faisant environ
350 000 mais une note de service d'ici
un chien voulez-vous acheter  l'
école de rugby l'école chanceuse est assise 32
Nouvelle-Zélande et puis après une heure il
était 13 tous drôles 20 minutes pour aller où
as-tu trouvé ce costume il prend l'
assiette au sol cinéaste rivière nord
sud ces jaunes vont tourner
ici je  je suppose que vous continuez sur cet
hyper entropique originaire de j'ai une
femme l'intégrité la vie est le rôle là-bas
ouais développeur nous arrivons sur le
howard dit parce que fait référence à une épine dans
une serviette mangé ils ne sortent jamais vers votre
voiture l'ouest de la Turquie
était  que mon café qui est Goldman Sachs
oh ouais était là et ils l'ont
frappé à notre porte offrent une
couverture avant que lui
le gars anglais ou sa batterie nuage à
neuf cents pieds au nord sur bravo alpha
geek mortel zéro bien sûr
réservé ou celui d'une production qui
s'imagine t'es prêt à tourner sans
le silencieux sur la butte pour carburant
Rob alternatif artificiel
t'es blessé